- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte.
Je suis heureuse de souhaiter, en
votre nom, la bienvenue au Premier
ministre de la République du
Congo.
Applaudissements
...
Merci beaucoup.
L'ordre du jour appelle la séance
de questions au gouvernement.
Chut.
S'il vous plaît.
La première question va être posée
par la présidente Cyrielle
Chatelain pour le groupe
écologiste.
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Le 17 mai, vous avez jugé
inconstitutionnelle la proposition
de loi d'abrogation de réforme des
retraites.
Le 23 mai, vous avez convoqué la
présidente de l'Assemblée à un
petit-déjeuner pour lui intimer
l'ordre d'abandonner son rôle de
présidente.
Les conséquences de ce
petit-déjeuner, nous les subissons
aujourd'hui.
Madame Yaël Braun-Pivet avait
jusqu'alors refusé d'outrepasser
son rôle.
Elle a depuis fait volte-face.
Je tiens à soutenir le travail
remarquable d'Eric Coquerel.
Il défend la tradition
républicaine de cette Assemblée.
Ma question est: dans une
démocratie chahutée par votre
gouvernement, où la séparation des
pouvoirs est un principe
fondamental de notre république,
jusqu'où êtes-vous prêts à aller
dans le dévoiement de nos
institutions pour ne pas perdre la
face?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Il y a la vérité sur nos retraites
et notre réforme: un déséquilibre
qui menaçait l'avenir de notre
système par répartition.
Il y a une réforme qui rétablit
l'équilibre à horizon 2030.
Elle tient compte de la situation
de chacun.
4 Français sur 10 vont pouvoir
partir avant 64 ans.
Madame la présidente, il y a aussi
la réalité des faits sur la
manière dont ce texte a été
construit et adopté.
Des mois de concertations avec les
partenaires sociaux, 175 heures de
débats parlementaires et des
décisions très claires du Conseil
constitutionnel, qui ont validé
l'essentiel du texte.
Madame la présidente, il y a enfin
la réalité sur votre attitude et
celle de vos alliés de la NUPES.
Il y a des cris, et de
l'obstruction pour empêcher
l'examen du texte.
Je vous rappelle que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui-même a intimé
l'ordre sur Twitter à la NUPES de
ne pas débattre et de ne pas voter
le report de l'âge.
Il a dit de ne pas débattre de cet
article.
Après des semaines
d'antiparlementarisme, nous
aboutissons logiquement à des
manoeuvres anticonstitutionnelles.
La proposition de loi que vous
évoquez aggraverait lourdement les
charges publiques, réduirait les
recettes.
Madame la présidente Chatelain, on
ne défend pas les institutions à
coups de propositions de loi
anticonstitutionnelles.
On ne ment pas aux Français avec
la plus grande démagogie en
parlant d'un texte dont chacun
sait ici pertinemment qu'il serait
censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel s'il parvenait au
bout de son cheminement
parlementaire.
Alors, madame la présidente,
jusqu'au bout, nous allons
défendre la réalité face à la
démagogie et la constitution face
à ceux qui la remettent en cause.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Madame la présidente...
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Madame la
Première ministre, l'insulte, dans
cet hémicycle, c'est vous.
Depuis des mois, vous mentez!
Les grands discours, ça suffit!
Notre démocratie est fragile.
Ce n'est pas un acquis.
Le dévoiement que vous faites
chaque jour de son fonctionnement
est dangereux.
Soyez sport!
Le 8 juin, acceptez votre défaite!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix pour le
groupe Les Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Tous les indicateurs le montrent:
le logement est en crise.
100.000 logements construits de
moins qu'il y a 15 ans.
Chute de 30% sur une année du
nombre de maisons individuelles
vendues.
Explosion des faillites de
promoteurs, de constructeurs
individuels, d'agences
immobilières: +83%.
Les causes de cette crise sont
malheureusement totalement
identifiées.
Il y a d'abord la hausse des prix
de construction à cause de la
guerre en Ukraine.
Il y a le renchérissement des
projets à cause des normes.
Il y a le manque de foncier
disponible.
Il y a aussi la hausse des taux
d'intérêt.
Les Français ne trouvent à
emprunter qu'autour de 4,5% sur 20
ans.
Il y a des refus de prêts par les
banques.
Madame la Première ministre, on
sait depuis 2017 que le logement
n'intéresse pas beaucoup le
président de la République.
Il a fait sienne cette idéologie
selon laquelle on construirait
trop en France.
Il faudrait que les Français
renoncent à leur rêve de la maison
individuelle.
Mais cette fois, la crise est là.
Pénurie de logements, destructions
d'emplois, baisse du pouvoir
d'achat...
Allez-vous répondre au cri
d'alarme que vous ont adressé les
professionnels de cette filière?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
L'offre de logement est
insuffisante ou inadaptée, dans
certains territoires.
Elle peut bloquer nos compatriotes
dans leurs projets de mobilité.
Elle peut être un frein à
l'emploi, particulièrement dans
les zones en forte tension, comme
les métropoles.
Cette situation résulte d'enjeux
structurels, dont les causes sont
multiples.
Il y a notamment la baisse du
nombre de permis de construire
délivrés.
Il y a aussi la hausse du prix du
foncier.
Il y a aussi des difficultés
conjoncturelles, avec la hausse
rapide des taux d'intérêt.
Cela freine à la demande de
logements.
Il y a les transactions
immobilières dans l'ancien.
Nous sommes bien conscients des
difficultés actuelles.
Le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé pour agir avec tous les
acteurs concernés.
Nous avons déjà annoncé des
premières mesures pour répondre à
ces difficultés.
Nous avons regardé comment
assouplir certaines règles d'accès
au crédit immobilier.
Nous avons aussi prévu l'achat de
10.000 logements par la Caisse des
dépôts et consignations.
Nous avons une politique
ambitieuse de rénovation
énergétique.
Nous l'avons lancée dans le
précédent quinquennat.
Avec tous les acteurs et avec les
élus locaux, nous voulons aller
encore plus loin.
Des mesures complémentaires vont
être présentées lors du Conseil
national de la refondation
consacré au logement.
Il va se réunir la semaine
prochaine.
Il a mobilisé de nombreux acteurs,
tous les acteurs impliqués sur ces
enjeux.
Je vais y participer
personnellement.
Ce sera l'occasion d'apporter des
réponses.
Je vous confirme que nous sommes à
l'écoute de toutes les
propositions sur ces sujets.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Olivier Marleix: Je ne suis pas
sûr que vous soyez totalement
consciente de l'urgence de la
crise.
Si vous n'avez pas de solutions,
permettez que les députés Les
Républicains vous en proposent,
une fois de plus.
Il faut libérer du foncier.
C'est l'urgence.
Il faut assouplir les règles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Laure
Lavalette pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Laure Lavalette: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, le
président a donc menti.
Dimanche 21 mai, le ministre de la
Justice a dit quelque chose de
faux.
Le président de la République a
menti.
Il a dit que 100% des OQTF
allaient être exécutées.
Cette énième promesse lancée par
vantardise ne sera pas tenue.
Elle abîme encore plus la
confiance entre le politique et un
peuple qui n'est plus préservé ni
protégé.
Fiasco de l'Ocean Viking,
humiliation de retour du Maghreb,
silence coupable face aux
provocations des Comores, c'est
tout le pays qui souffre sous le
joug de votre action.
Qui allez-vous dédire?
Le président ou le garde des
Sceaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
J'excuse l'absence du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est actuellement
en déplacement officiel en
Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Avant de vous répondre
actuellement et par des chiffres,
je ne partage pas votre assertion
selon laquelle la France serait un
pays qui plie.
Elle ne plie pas!
C'est un pays qui est fort.
C'est un pays qui défend sa place
en Europe et sur la scène
internationale.
Quand on aime son pays, on ne dit
pas que la France plie ou qu'elle
craque.
Il y a une dynamique qui a été
créée en 2017.
Nous avons obtenu des résultats.
Nous avons augmenté la durée
maximale de rétention à 90 jours.
Les résultats sont là.
Entre 2017 et 2019, le nombre
d'expulsions a augmenté
sensiblement dans notre pays.
Il y a eu la période du Covid.
Le monde entier et l'Europe ont
connu des perturbations en matière
de respect des OQTF.
C'était le cas chez tous les
voisins.
C'est factuel.
Ensuite, il y a eu une instruction
du ministre de l'Intérieur.
Elle a permis de placer en centre
de rétention administrative en
priorité les personnes étrangères
qui ont été responsables de
délits.
Tout cela nous a permis d'avoir
des chiffres tangibles.
850 étrangers connus pour des
faits de radicalisation ont été
éloignés depuis 2017.
3615 étrangers ont été des auteurs
de troubles à l'ordre public.
Ce sont des résultats et nous
allons en avoir d'autres.
Nous allons débuter des
discussions prochainement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Laure Lavalette: Rien n'égale
votre mauvaise foi, sinon votre
bilan catastrophique.
Les Français ont des yeux pour
voir.
Vous ne répondez à rien.
Vous n'assumez rien!
Le Rassemblement National est prêt
à agir.
Nos collègues LR ne se gênent pas
pour copier notre projet.
Même s'ils oublient la priorité
nationale, comme de mauvais
copieurs.
Mais voilà.
Le Rassemblement National est prêt
à rendre aux Français le contrôle.
Marine Le Pen fera ce que vous ne
faites pas, dans quatre ans!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Frédéric
Descrozaille pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Frédéric Descrozaille: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Je voudrais rendre un hommage à
Frédéric Leclerc-Imhoff.
Il est décédé il y a un an en
Ukraine dans le cadre de son
métier de journaliste.
Ce drame nous rappelle la portée
irremplaçable de ce métier pour la
démocratie.
Il n'est pas de liberté de décider
et d'agir sans liberté de savoir
et de connaître.
Cette mission est remplie au
risque de leur vie par les femmes
et les hommes qui le conduisent,
notamment dans des cadres
conflictuels comme celui de
l'Ukraine.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Elle porte sur le rapport de la
Cour des comptes qui est sorti
récemment et qui recommande aux
pouvoirs publics d'adopter une
stratégie de réduction de notre
cheptel en France.
Outre l'incongruité de magistrats
qui auraient des compétences
d'agriculteurs ou d'agronomes et
qui ne font aucune distinction
entre les différentes catégories
d'élevage et de cheptel, je note,
que dans cette recommandation, il
n'est tenu aucun compte de
l'impact sur l'importation de
viande, qui serait pire que celle
que nous produisons en France.
Elle ne tient pas compte non plus
des effets sur le lait.
On continue de vivre dans un pays
qui croit qu'il aura encore du
fromage et du lait sans viande.
Nous allons tout droit vers une
espèce d'épisode à la "Black
Mirror", où les riches vont
pouvoir accéder à tous les
produits et les pauvres vont
manger de la viande cellulaire.
Ma question: qu'avez-vous à dire
aux éleveurs dans le cadre
d'attaques incessantes sur leur
métier?
Quelle est la doctrine du
gouvernement en matière de
concours des pouvoirs publics pour
l'investissement dans la recherche
sur les protéines alimentaires et
la transition agroécologique des
élevages?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je suis élue de Normandie.
Je connais l'importance de
l'élevage bovin pour nos
territoires comme pour notre
économie.
Je connais l'engagement des
éleveurs et leur inquiétude, en
particulier après le rapport de la
Cour des comptes, la semaine
dernière.
Nous avons un modèle d'élevage
bovin dont nous pouvons être
fiers.
Un modèle d'élevage dont je veux
affirmer qu'il a un avenir dans
notre pays.
C'est pour cela que le
gouvernement apporte un soutien
sans faille à nos éleveurs, en
faisant la transparence sur
l'évolution des prix de
l'alimentation animale, à travers
la PAC où l'élevage est la filière
la plus soutenue.
Je n'oublie pas non plus que
l'élevage peut avoir des effets
bénéfiques pour notre
environnement.
Chaque année, les prairies
stockent 8 millions de tonnes de
CO2 et l'élevage permet la
construction d'un réseau
d'infrastructures agroécologiques
utiles notamment pour les sols.
Pour autant, les défis devant nous
sont majeurs.
Nous devons baisser nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre, mener
notre transition agricole et
accompagner la structuration des
filières.
Vous savez, vous qui suivez le
travail que nous menons sur les
filières, depuis 2017.
Nous sommes prêts et nous nous
engageons déjà.
Oui, le système va devoir évoluer.
Mais non, il ne sera pas la
variable d'ajustement.
Pour être réussie, la transition
écologique et agricole doit se
faire avec les Français, avec les
éleveurs, et non pas contre eux.
Je veux donner aux éleveurs de la
visibilité sur les défis devant
eux et bâtir avec eux un avenir
soutenable économiquement et
environnementalement.
Je compte sur eux pour s'engager
pleinement dans ce travail.
C'est le sens de la planification
écologique que nous menons avec le
ministre de la Transition
écologique de la cohésion des
territoires.
Cela vous dérange, que je réponde
à la question?
Elle se fait huer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Vous n'avez
pas la parole!
Vous n'avez pas la parole!
Madame la Première ministre, nous
vous écoutons.
- Elisabeth Borne: C'est le sens
de la planification écologique que
nous menons avec le ministre
Christophe Béchu et le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la
Souveraineté alimentaire, Marc
Fesneau.
Nous allons présenter la stratégie
complète en juin.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Charles
de Courson.
- Charles de Courson: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Chut!
- Charles de Courson: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Le groupe LIOT a déposé une
proposition de loi visant à
l'abrogation du recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite et à la
création d'une conférence de
financement du système de
retraites.
Cette proposition de loi a été
déclarée recevable par le bureau
de l'Assemblée nationale et a été
inscrite le 8 juin à l'ordre du
jour de notre Assemblée.
Ce matin, le président de la
commission des finances, saisi par
la présidente de la commission aux
affaires sociales, l'a aussi
déclarée recevable.
Cette proposition de loi vise à un
double objectif.
Elle va permettre enfin à
l'Assemblée nationale de se
prononcer sur la hausse de deux
années de l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite.
Deuxièmement, elle va lancer une
conférence de financement du
système de retraites pour aboutir
à des propositions équilibrées
socialement et financièrement.
Elle pourrait être intégrée dès
2024 dans la prochaine loi de
financement de la Sécurité
sociale.
Certaines rumeurs courent selon
lesquelles le gouvernement
pourrait avoir recours au vote
bloqué de l'article 44.3 de la
constitution.
D'autres rumeurs évoquent une
autre réunion du bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale pour écarter
cette proposition.
Il y a encore d'autres rumeurs.
Ma question est toute simple.
Le gouvernement laissera-t-il
l'Assemblée nationale se prononcer
sur cette proposition de loi ou
aura-t-il de nouveau recours à des
dispositions visant à empêcher le
vote?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Acclamations
Je vous remercie!
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt, ministre du Travail, de
l'Insertion et du Plein emploi.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Vous avez déposé une proposition
de loi.
Pour ce qui concerne les questions
relatives à leur recevabilité, au
nom de la séparation des pouvoirs,
le gouvernement n'a pas à se
prononcer sur les procédures
propres à l'Assemblée nationale.
Ceci étant, monsieur le député,
vous qui, depuis plusieurs
décennies, bataillez sur les
projets de loi de finances, vous
savez pertinemment qu'en proposant
une charge de 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires, votre proposition
nous paraît irrecevable et
constitutionnelle.
Monsieur le député, votre
proposition de loi dégraderait les
comptes publics de 15 milliards
d'euros.
Comment allez-vous la financer?
Allez-vous augmenter les
cotisations de 1000 euros par
année sur tous les Français?
Allez-vous diminuer les pensions
de retraites?
Allez-vous sabrer le budget de
l'Education nationale?
Comment allez-vous financer ce
budget?
Vous ne pouvez plus venir dans
cet hémicycle et faire la leçon
sur les finances publiques.
Avec votre proposition de loi, si
elle était adoptée, vous mettez à
mal et en danger le système par
répartition.
Vous dégradez les finances
publiques.
Vous tournez le dos à tout esprit
de responsabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur de Courson?
- Charles de Courson: Je regrette
que cela ne soit pas la Première
ministre en personne qui ait
répondu à cette question.
Je voudrais dire à monsieur
Dussopt que cette proposition de
loi dégrade les comptes publics de
270 millions en 2023.
La conférence sociale...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie!
Monsieur le ministre.
Il faut attendre deux secondes.
Il faut que l'on puisse vous
écouter.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Comment vous sentez-vous?
Vous êtes dans une position
extrémiste!
Protestations
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Sarah
Legrain pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
Protestations
Un peu de silence! Vous ne voulez
pas écouter votre
collègue?
- Sarah Legrain: Samedi dernier,
Justine Triet a remporté la Palme
d'or au festival de Cannes.
En 76 ans, c'est la 10e palme
reçue par un film français, la
troisième par une femme.
Cette palme fait la fierté de la
France.
Il y aurait de quoi l'applaudir
ici.
Il y aurait de quoi l'applaudir,
Même si Emmanuel Macron n'a
toujours pas jugé bon de la
saluer.
Il a bien félicité Erdogan pour sa
réélection.
Mais il faut dire qu'Erdogan ne
critique pas la répression.
J'ai été estomaquée devant
l'ignorance crasse du financement
du cinéma, devant leur vision
réactionnaire de l'artiste, entre
amuseurs de foire et valets du
pouvoir.
Dites-moi ce qui vous distingue de
l'extrême droite et de Vincent
Bolloré?
Justine Triet fait plus pour
l'exception culturelle française
que vous, madame la ministre de la
Culture.
Elle fait vibrer les origines
résistantes de notre festival de
Cannes.
Il n'avait pas vocation de devenir
ce tapis rouge sous les bruits des
casseroles.
Elle donne voix à l'alerte lancée
par de nombreux artistes et
professionnels sur les logiques de
concentration qui menacent
l'indépendance et la diversité du
cinéma français.
Défendre l'exception culturelle,
ce n'est pas nommer un libéral à la
tête du CNC.
Vous n'avez rien à dire des
libertés qui nous appartiennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie!
La parole est à madame Rima Abdul
Malak.
- Rima Abdul Malak: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Premièrement, je tiens à féliciter
Justine Triet et ses producteurs
pour cette Palme d'or.
On est très fiers de cette Palme
d'or.
C'est la 10e pour la France et la
troisième pour une femme.
Ce n'est pas rien.
Deuxièmement, je ne jamais
contesté le principe de sa
déclaration.
Les artistes sont libres de
s'exprimer partout, où ils
veulent, quand ils veulent.
C'est un principe intangible de
notre démocratie.
Je le défendrai toujours.
Ensuite, je ne demande pas du tout
de la gratitude, mais de
l'honnêteté intellectuelle, et à
vous aussi.
Il faut me donner des chiffres qui
prouveraient que le président et
ses ministres ont détruit
l'exception culturelle ou ont créé
une marchandisation de la culture.
C'est tout le contraire.
Nous n'avons fait que renforcer ce
système dont nous sommes fiers et
qui existe depuis 1946 avec la
création du CNC.
Nous avons créé de nouvelles taxes
pour faire entrer de nouvelles
ressources dans le budget du CNC.
Il y a notamment la taxe sur les
plates-formes.
Nous avons porté au niveau
européen la directive sur le droit
d'auteur et une autre directive.
Cette majorité a défendu cette
exception culturelle haut et fort.
Elle est bien vivante.
Pendant la crise, nous avons
déployé des centaines de millions
d'euros d'aides.
4,5 millions de de pass culture
ont été financés par l'Etat pour
aider les jeunes à aller au cinéma
et créer le désir du cinéma dans
notre pays.
Voilà l'exception culturelle,
madame la députée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Thomas
Ménagé pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Thomas Ménagé: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances.
Le président de la République a
déclaré que la France se
réindustrialisait.
Notre industrie est
considérablement affaiblie depuis
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron.
La part de l'industrie
manufacturière a baissé de 4,4% et
a perdu 1 point dont la valeur
ajoutée globale.
Pour tenter de réindustrialiser le
pays, vous enchaînez les plans,
sans aucun résultat.
Malheureusement, dans nos
territoires, les seuls plans que
nous connaissons, ce sont les
plans sociaux.
Dans ma
circonscription de
Châlette-sur-Loing, une nouvelle
vague de suppressions de postes
menace l'usine
Hutchinson.
Ce sont désormais 170 emplois
supplémentaires qui sont menacés.
Avec Marine Le Pen, nous avons des
solutions pour réindustrialiser le
pays et répondre aux différents
enjeux.
Pendant que vous vous réjouissez
de l'arrivée d'investisseurs
chinois ou de Taïwan, il y a une
filiale industrielle française qui
est démantelée.
Que comptez-vous faire
concrètement pour sauvegarder les
170 postes menacées dans cette
usine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Vous vous indignez, mais
l'indignation n'a jamais créé un
seul emploi.
Notre politique industrielle, si.
Pendant que vous discutez, et
j'attends toujours les
propositions du Rassemblement
National sur l'industrie, nous
avons ouvert 300 usines
supplémentaires depuis deux
années.
Nous avons engagé la
réindustrialisation de la France.
Nous avons obtenu que l'Union
Européenne change radicalement de
politique pour que nous puissions
apporter des aides d'Etat, des
crédits d'impôts, des subventions
au développement de notre
industrie, comme le faisaient la
Chine et les Etats-Unis.
Nous avons décidé de réserver le
bénéfice du bonus électrique aux
seuls véhicule électriques qui
respecteraient les normes
environnementales les plus
strictes, c'est-à-dire ceux
produits sur notre territoire.
Nous avons, ce matin, inauguré la
première usine de batteries
électriques en France et en
Europe.
Nous allons créer 10.000 emplois
industriels.
Vous appelez cela du vent?
Le vent, ce sont vos discours!
Notre politique, ce sont les
résultats.
Nous avons, avec le ministre de
l'Industrie, Roland Lescure, sauvé
l'usine Duralex.
Vous étiez bien contents, quand le
gouvernement est venu protéger des
emplois et sauver votre industrie
sur votre territoire.
Nous n'avons jamais laissé tomber
aucune usine, ni aucun ouvrier.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le député?
- Thomas Ménagé: Par rapport aux
170 postes, qu'est-ce qu'il y a,
comme réponse?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
- Jérémie Patrier-Leitus: Ma
question s'adresse à madame la
ministre chargée des Petites et
Moyennes entreprises, du Commerce,
de l'Artisanat .
Céramistes, dentellières,
diamantaires, ébénistes, orfèvres,
fresquistes...
Ces métiers sont des vocations.
Comme le disait Stendhal, "La
vocation, c'est avoir pour métier
sa passion".
Notre pays peut s'enorgueillir de
ses 180 métiers d'art et des
savoir-faire d'exception que le
monde nous envie.
Ces métiers d'art font la fierté
de notre pays, contribuent au
rayonnement de la France dans le
monde, à la vitalité de nos
territoires ruraux notamment.
Ils ont bâti la cathédrale
Notre-Dame de Paris.
Que seraient les jardins de
Versailles sans les fontainiers,
les sculpteurs sur pierre?
Que serait la mode sans
boutonniers, chapeliers et
modistes?
Ce sont des gardiens passionnés de
l'intelligence de la main, les
héritiers d'un patrimoine
immatériel et d'une valeur
inestimable qu'il nous faut
transmettre.
Pourtant, aucun plan national
d'envergure n'avait été dédié à
ces métiers d'art.
Je souhaite saluer avec force la
stratégie de soutien aux métiers
d'art que vous avez mis en place
avec la ministre de la Culture.
Pouvez-vous détailler ce plan de
340 millions d'euros et notamment
la manière dont il va se décliner
dans les territoires?
Pouvez-vous donner quelques
mesures phares des 5 axes de votre
stratégie?
Pouvez-vous nous expliquer comment
vous avez donné envie à ces jeunes
de se former à ces métiers
passionnants, ces métiers de la
main, ces métiers de demain?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Jérémie
Patrier-Leitus, effectivement,
nous avons ce matin avec la
ministre de la Culture présenté
notre stratégie nationale en
faveur des métiers d'art.
Semble-t-il, il n'intéresse pas
tout cet hémicycle.
Ce sont des savoir-faire
séculaires.
Ce ne sont pas moins de 160 000
entreprises, notamment du
patrimoine vivant.
Les métiers d'art, ce sont 120.000
artisans d'art qui tous les jours
transmettent et font rayonner la
France dans le monde entier.
Effectivement, nous avons, après
des mois d'échanges et notamment
avec l'institut national des
métiers d'art, le mobilier
national, la manufacture de
Sèvres, nous avons présenté ce
matin une stratégie nationale que
je suggère à certains d'écouter,
ne serait-ce que par respect pour
les artisans d'art.
Un potentiel économique que je
viens de vous rappeler, c'est 19
milliards d'euros, dont 8
milliards d'euros à l'export.
Ce sont aussi de multiples emplois
que l'intelligence artificielle ne
nous ravira pas.
Pour ceux que ça intéresse,
l'étude faite par les créateurs de
ChatGPT, parmi les 34 métiers qui
ne pourront pas être avalés par
l'intelligence artificielle, il y
a les artisans d'art que vous avez
cités.
Nous allons créer un CFA dédié.
Nous allons financer plus
massivement le tourisme et le
savoir-faire pour ouvrir les
portes de ces entreprises du
patrimoine vivant et les ateliers
des maîtres d'art.
Nous allons renforcer
considérablement le label
Entreprise du patrimoine vivant.
L'objectif est d'avoir 2500
entreprises du patrimoine vivant
dans l'année qui vient.
Nous allons, avec la ministre de
la Culture, renforcer le
financement à l'export de ces
entreprises.
Il faut mieux les reconnaître et
les aider à se connaître entre
elles pour répondre ensemble à des
projets et les faire connaître,
notamment à nos plus jeunes pour
assurer la pérennité de ces
métiers.
Il n'y a pas de hasard, que des
rendez-vous.
Nous serons au rendez-vous des
métiers d'art.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Marie-Christine
Dalloz.
- Marie-Christine Dalloz: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le garde des Sceaux,
jeudi dernier, les corps d'une
femme et de ses deux enfants ont
été retrouvés sans vie à leur
domicile, tués de multiples coups
de couteau dans la circonscription
du président Olivier Marleix.
Cette femme s'était présentée la
veille au commissariat de police.
Dans la matinée de lundi, le
procureur de la République de
Chartres a annoncé la mise en
détention provisoire de
l'ex-conjoint de la victime.
Un homme déjà condamné à un an
d'emprisonnement en septembre 2021
pour des faits de violence envers
sa femme et sa fille était en
période de probation.
Comment la plainte de son épouse
n'a pas pu donner l'alerte?
Les hommages se sont multipliés
durant tout le week-end.
Aujourd'hui, les mots ne suffisent
plus.
36 féminicides par conjoint ou
ex-conjoint ont été dénombrés
depuis le début de l'année, en
France, contre 24 à la même époque
l'an passé.
Les chiffres s'aggravent sans que
nous soyons en capacité d'inverser
la tendance.
Alors même que le président Macron
en avait fait une grande cause du
quinquennat en 2017.
Ce drame sordide a décimé une
famille et pose la question
récurrente de la protection des
femmes victimes de violences et de
l'efficacité des politiques
publiques mises en place
aujourd'hui.
Le dernier rapport du Haut conseil
soulignait l'impuissance des
pouvoirs publics.
L'histoire se répète
dramatiquement.
Les effets d'annonce ne suffisent
plus.
Il faut écouter ces femmes.
Il faut mettre un place un arsenal
juridique capable de mettre en
place la progression que la
République leur doit.
Combien de victimes devront mourir
encore pour que l'action soit
efficace?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée, la plainte qui
a été déposée la veille, de ce que
j'en sais, concerne en réalité un
cambriolage.
Je souhaite qu'il n'y ait pas
d'amalgame sur ces questions.
Entre un cambriolage dénoncé et
des violences avérées, il y a un
certain nombre de nuances qui ne
peuvent ici échapper à personne.
Pour le reste, je voudrais dire
que nous avons considérablement
progressé dans les mesures de
protections qui ont été prises.
Pardon de vous livrer quelques
chiffres.
Ils sont aussi dérisoires que les
mots face à de tels drames.
En 2019, madame la députée, c'est
300 téléphones déployés Grave
danger.
Nous en sommes aujourd'hui à plus
de 1500.
Le nombre des forces intérieures a
été décuplé.
De nombreux drames ont été évités.
1020 bracelets anti-rapprochement
ont également été posés.
634 interventions des services de
police et de gendarmerie ont eu
lieu.
Sur les bracelets
anti-rapprochement, nous sommes
allés plus vite que nos amis
espagnols.
Nous allons lancer un bracelet
anti-rapprochement nouvelle
génération dans les jours qui
viennent.
Il aura une meilleure couverture
de réseau et une autonomie
supérieure.
Les ordonnances de protection ont
vu leur nombre augmenter de 157%
depuis 2016.
4000 ordonnances ont été livrées
par an.
Nous sommes passés de 47 jours à 6
jours.
Nous allons et nous travaillons à
obtenir une ordonnance de
protection dans les 24 heures.
On est passé de 22.000
condamnations à 44.000 depuis
2017.
Je dois aussi souligner
l'excellent travail mené par vos
collègues.
Nous allons en tirer les
conséquences dans les jours, dans
les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Marie-Christine
Dialloz.
- Marie-Christine Dalloz: La
victime s'était déjà rendue au
commissariat deux fois.
Je pense à la peur quotidienne de
ces femmes.
Il faut faire encore plus pour
protéger les femmes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jimmy Pahun.
- Jimmy Pahun: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Un accord doit être
trouvé sur la pollution plastique.
La France souhaite cet accord.
Avec plusieurs groupes politiques,
le groupe démocrate a lancé un
appel en faveur d'un tel traité
avec nos collègues de Renaissance,
LFI, Horizons, et LIOT.
Nous avons appelé à soutenir les
objectifs de la coalition.
D'abord, la réduction de la
production de la consommation de
plastique ensuite, l'écoconception
des plastiques.
Enfin, une collecte est un
moyen.
Monsieur le ministre, toute cette
semaine, nos pensées vont
accompagner les négociateurs
français et ceux de nos
partenaires de la coalition, car
Paris devra poser les jalons d'un
traité contraignant et ambitieux.
La solution, c'est la réduction,
encore et toujours la réduction.
Par la suppression du polymère et
des additifs problématiques,
toxiques et non-recyclables, c'est
l'esprit des lois.
La France a une législation à
l'avant-garde des pollution
plastique.
Il faut assurer sa bonne
application et quand c'est
nécessaire, prendre des mesures
complémentaires pour atteindre les
objectifs fixés.
100% de plastique recyclé en 2025.
L'accompagnement public des
entreprises est indispensable.
Comment garantir l'atteinte de ces
objectifs, et le respect des
obligations et interdictions de
certaines lois, alors que la
production plastique augmente les
jours?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, merci pour
votre question, merci pour
l'initiative transpartisane qui
s'inscrit dans la continuité d'une
PPL que vous aviez déposé ici.
85% de la pollution de nos océans
est constitué du plastique.
En l'espace de 50 ans, se sont 7
milliards de tonnes de plastique
qui se sont répandus dans la
nature à l'échelle de la planète.
Vous l'avez dit: non seulement, on
continue à avoir une production de
plastique qui augmente, mais avec
des chiffres qui sont alarmants
quand on les prolonge.
Entre 2050 et 2060, pour les
experts, il se passera de choses
pour l'environnement.
10% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pourrait dépasser la
masse du poisson.
Il faut faire en sorte de se
mobiliser à l'échelle mondiale.
80% des plastiques franchissent au
moins une frontière dans leur vie.
Tout l'enjeu de ce qui est en
train de se passer, avec ce
deuxième cycle de négociations...
C'est bien de poser les bases avec
ce traité contraignant et
ambitieux.
La coalition à laquelle la France
appartient, dirigée par le Rwanda
et la Norvège, est au travail.
Il est de longue haleine.
S'il n'y a pas
scepticisme sur le plastique,
certains pays producteurs sont
nettement moins allants que ne le
sont l'Europe et l'Afrique sur ce
sujet.
Le soutien des parlementaires reste
crucial.
La France, dans ce domaine, n'est
peut-être pas exemplaire, car on
peut progresser, mais il y a des
initiatives que l'on peut
valoriser.
Nous sommes le premier pays au
monde à avoir interdit au 1er
janvier la vaisselle jetable dans
les lieux de restauration rapide.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sébastien Jumel.
- Sébastien Jumel: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Sur la réforme des retraites, les
Français attendent un vrai vote à
l'Assemblée.
Pas de bla-bla, pas de combine.
On n'en veut plus.
On n'en peut plus.
Juste un vote.
Depuis janvier, vous mobilisez
toute la gamme des artifices de
procédure en allant gratter les
fonds de tiroir pour corseter le
débat.
Pour empêcher la voix de ceux qui
sont opposés à votre projet,
d'impôts sur la vie, pour empêcher
qu'un vote vienne balayer ce
texte.
Vous avez gagné du temps.
Vous avez tenté de discréditer
votre position, parce que vous
n'aimez pas la contradiction.
Vous n'aimez pas le débat.
Vous n'aimez pas la démocratie.
Vous rêvez même de supprimer les
contre-pouvoirs.
Vous avez refusé un vote pour ne
pas le perdre avec le 49.3.
Demain, en commission, le 8 juin,
ce sera une séance de rattrapage.
Les Français l'attendent et vous
regardent.
Soit vous assumez le risque du
vote, soit vous continuez à raser
les murs et inventez une nouvelle
partie de billard à trois bandes
pour éviter encore l'expression
d'une décision pleinement
démocratique.
Si vous prenez ce chemin, les
Français vous verront.
Ils verront votre lâcheté
politique.
Ce ne seront plus des casseroles
que vous traînerez, mais un boulet
pour l'Histoire.
Si vous prenez ce chemin alors que
les Français ne vous supportent
plus, vous accentuerez la crise
démocratique.
Nous vous invitons solennellement
à laisser se dérouler pleinement
l'examen de cette loi en rappelant
que jamais un gouvernement, aucune
majorité ne s'est réfugiée
derrière l'article 40 d'une
proposition de loi d'un groupe
dans sa journée d'initiative
commentaire.
Ne prenez pas deux ans de vie aux
Français en vous cachant derrière
cet article comme vous l'avez déjà
fait derrière le 49.3.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, permettez-moi
de ne pas préjuger du débat qui se
déroulera en commission sur la
proposition de loi, ni de la suite
de l'examen de ce texte.
J'ai dit en réponse à un premier
intervenant qu'à nos yeux, aux
yeux du gouvernement, cette
proposition de loi crée une charge
très forte sur les finances
publiques.
A notre sens, ça justifie son
irrecevabilité et son caractère
non-constitutionnel.
Je voudrais aussi pointer deux
contradictions dans la question
que vous avez posée.
Vous nous dites que faire droit à
la Constitution serait avoir
recours à des subterfuges
constitutionnels pour gagner du
temps.
En réalité, qui dans cet hémicycle
pendant tout le débat sur la
réforme des retraites fait le pari
de l'obstruction et du
ralentissement des débats?
Qui a déposé 20.000 amendements?
Les 20.000 amendements venaient de
la NUPES.
Au-delà de ça, il y a une autre
contradiction.
Elle est entre la position que
vous avez défendue lors du débat,
et le texte cosigné avec Charles
de Courson.
Vous aviez une position qui
consistait à défendre la retraite
à 60 ans.
Là, vous signez une proposition de
loi qui conserve la retraite à 62
ans.
Vous avez fait campagne et vous
vous êtes mobilisés pour défendre
les régimes spéciaux.
Vous signez une proposition de loi
qui indique le contraire.
C'est une forme de reniement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse,
monsieur le député?
- Sébastien Jumel: L'article 40
vues par le gouvernement, c'est
l'article des 40 voleurs des deux
ans de vie qu'ils veulent voler
aux Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Claudia Rouaux.
- Claudia Rouaux: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, la
crise du logement est une réalité
constatée par les professionnels
de l'immobilier, les élus locaux
vous alertent les uns après les
autres sur l'urgence de la
situation.
En matière de logement social, la
Fondation Abbé Pierre vient de
tirer la sonnette d'alarme car la
situation est catastrophique.
Faut-il rappeler que 2,3 millions
de ménages attendent un logement
social et que notre pays compte 4
millions de mal-logés?
Oui, il y a urgence à relancer ce
secteur à travers une politique de
l'habitat ambitieuse et
volontariste.
C'est une question de dignité pour
permettre à tout un chacun de se
loger.
Depuis 2017, les offices publics
de l'habitat ont fait les frais
d'une politique publique qui
consistait à les fragiliser à
travers des dispositifs de
réduction de loyer de solidarité,
la baisse des appels ou encore
l'augmentation de la TVA sur les
constructions.
A cela s'ajoutent la crise de
l'énergie, l'inflation des coûts
de construction et de rénovation
du parc de social, la forte
augmentation du livret A, certes
bienvenue pour les particuliers,
mais qui pèse sur le financement
du logement social.
Face à ce constat, un triple enjeu
doit être relevé.
Favoriser la relance de la
construction de logements sociaux,
accélérer la rénovation du parc
HLM pour remplir les objectifs en
matière de transition écologique,
et tenir une approche
décentralisée en tenant compte de
la diversité des territoires.
Investir dans le logement social,
c'est investir dans le pouvoir
d'achat, lutter contre les
inégalités dans le pouvoir
d'achat.
Alors que les conclusions du
Conseil national de la refondation
sur le logement sont attendues le
5 juin prochain, madame la
Première ministre, à quand un
débat au parlement pour entendre
nos propositions?
Quel engagement fort prenez-vous
pour relancer dès à présent ce
secteur?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, la Première
ministre l'a dit tout à l'heure.
La crise du logement, nous ne la
contestons pas.
Nous travaillons dessus depuis des
mois.
Le gouvernement a agi.
MaPrimeRénov', c'est ce
gouvernement et cette majorité qui
l'a mise en place.
Le plafonnement du loyer lors de
la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat,
c'est ce gouvernement qui l'a mis
en place.
L'augmentation de 3,5% des APL
lors de la loi pouvoir d'achat,
c'est ce gouvernement qui l'a mis
en place.
Le travail sur l'évolution de
MaPrimeRénov', c'est aussi ce
gouvernement qui l'a mis en place.
La mise en place du crédit pour
les plus fragiles pour accompagner
MaPrimeRénov', c'est aussi ce
gouvernement.
Vous avez rappelé que le 5 juin
prochain, et la Première ministre
a dit qu'elle y assistera, c'est
vous dire à quel point nous sommes
attachés à ce sujet, nous
remettrons la restitution du
Conseil national de la refondation
qui a fait travailler plus de 200
acteurs du logement sur ces
questions.
Il y a quelques jours, on disait
que c'était un moment exceptionnel
de mobilisation des acteurs.
J'étais il y a quelques jours avec
la Fondation Abbé Pierre, à
l'inauguration d'une pension de
famille dans la résidence chère à
l'Abbé Pierre.
Je peux vous assurer que l'accueil
de la fondation a été de grande
qualité.
Nous allons continuer à travailler
avec la représentation nationale
qui était présente dans le Conseil
national de la refondation, qui a
donné ses propositions.
Le CNH est présidé par l'un
d'entre vous.
Ce travail, c'est un travail de
grande qualité.
Cela viendra compléter les
propositions du CNR.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse,
madame Claudia Rouaux?
- Claudia Rouaux: A vous entendre,
tout va bien.
42 milliards pour les logements
sociaux en 2016.
35,4 en 2023.
Madame la Première ministre,
puisque vous avez proposé au
président Olivier Marleix un
débat, eh bien débattons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Florian Chauche.
- Florian Chauche: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Votre réforme des retraites était
censée sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition.
Elle devait combler le déficit à
venir.
12 milliards d'économies par an
d'après Gabriel Attal en janvier.
18 milliards pour Olivier Dussopt
en février.
Aujourd'hui, la Cour des comptes
estime que la réforme va se
traduire par un surcoût jusqu'à la
fin 2024.
Vous deviez combler le déficit, et
c'est raté.
Vous faites travailler les
Français deux ans de plus sans
solutionner le problème.
Si vous voulez sauver notre
système de retraite par
répartition, il faut augmenter les
salaires, arrêter les cadeaux aux
grandes entreprises, supprimer les
exonérations de cotisations
inutiles et faire participer les
gens qui en ont les moyens.
Le 8 juin, le groupe LIOT
utilisera sa niche parlementaire
pour abroger votre réforme et
permettre l'organisation d'une
conférence sur le financement de
notre système de retraite.
C'est la voie du dialogue et de
l'apaisement.
Il faut la saisir.
Au lieu de cela, vous continuez
votre passage en force et vous
avez méprisé les organisations
syndicales.
Vous avez fait passer votre
réforme contre l'avis des
Français.
Vous voulez aujourd'hui bâillonner
notre Assemblée.
Les déclarations de ministres sur
cette proposition de loi, dont
votre déclaration, se multiplient.
Ce matin, Yaël Braun-Pivet disait
qu'il ne devait pas y avoir de
débat sur cet article qui est
clairement anticonstitutionnel.
Ne vous en déplaise, ni les
membres du gouvernement, ni vous,
madame la présidente, n'est apte à
juger de la constitutionnalité de
cette loi.
D'ailleurs, vous l'avez jugée
recevable il y a quelques
semaines.
Votre peur de voir cette Assemblée
voter l'abrogation de la réforme
des retraites vous conduit aux
pires excès.
Il faut savoir raison garder.
Le président de la commission des
finances a jugé la proposition de
loi recevable.
Nous devons débattre maintenant et
la voter.
D'ici là, les Français me
manifesteront mardi prochain pour
vous dire encore leur opposition à
cette réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, vous avez
donné lecture d'une partie des
éléments du rapport annuel de la
Cour des comptes.
En fait, ce document de la Cour
des comptes devrait vous
satisfaire.
Que dit-il?
Il dit que l'effet notre réforme
est progressif.
Elle n'a pas la brutalité que vous
présentez.
Il dit que cet effet va avoir un
coût à court terme.
En sept ans, les petites retraites
seront revalorisées, les carrières
longues seront revalorisées.
Ce rapport annuel de la Cour des
comptes s'intéresse au régime
général.
Si vous aviez lu le rapport dans
son intégralité, vous verriez que
si on regarde tous régimes
confondus, l'équilibre financier
est au rendez-vous.
Tous les chiffres que vous avez
cités sont aussi dans l'étude
d'impact du projet de loi de
financement pour la Sécurité
sociale.
Vous auriez dû lire un tel procès
contre ce projet de loi.
La réforme que nous avons
présentée permet de garantir une
meilleure répartition.
Votre proposition de loi mettrait
à mal cela.
Nous allons continuer à nous
opposer à cette mauvaise
proposition de loi.
Elle est irrecevable et
irresponsable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Stéphane Buchou.
- Stéphane Buchou: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
François Braun, ministre de la
Santé et de la Prévention.
En raison d'un afflux important de
patients, les services d'urgence
du département de la Vendée ont dû
être fermés temporairement
plusieurs heures ces dernières
semaines.
Aux Sables d'Olonne, après la nuit
de samedi à dimanche dernier, ce
sera encore le cas entre ce soir
et demain matin.
D'autres villes du département
sont malheureusement touchées par
ces fermetures en pointillés, et
ont annoncé peu de temps en amont
de leur manque d'effectivité.
Cela génère de l'anxiété et
alimente l'angoisse des familles
et des patients.
La prise en charge doit être
parfois rapide.
J'ai rencontré les équipes
médicales et la direction de
l'hôpital des Sables d'Olonne.
Je salue leur dévouement au
service de la population.
Je veux aussi témoigner du travail
réalisé au mieux.
En même temps que les réservations
dans les campings battent leur
plein, les plannings des centres
hospitaliers ont du mal à se
remplir.
On connaît les causes.
Elles ne datent pas d'hier.
Les professionnels que j'ai
rencontrés saluent les mesures que
nous avons courageusement prises.
Malheureusement, elles ne portent
pas leurs fruits suffisamment
vite.
Qu'il s'agisse de la suppression
du numerus clausus ou de la
proposition de loi de la part de
Stéphanie Rist.
Monsieur le ministre, je ne veux
pas être alarmiste ou fataliste,
en laissant penser que nous ne
sommes pas en mesure de faire
face, mais alors que beaucoup de
nos compatriotes s'apprêtent à
partir en vacances sur les
littoraux, quelles mesures sont
envisagées afin de prévenir ces
situations et éviter qu'elles se
reproduisent?
Est-il envisageable d'envisager la
mobilité du personnel soignant?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, je vous
remercie d'avoir salué
l'engagement des professionnels
des services d'urgence qui restent
sur le pont.
Je rappelle la crise de l'été
dernier sous l'autorité de la
Première ministre.
Nous avons été amenés à prendre un
certain nombre de mesures, en
particulier la promotion de la
régulation médicale.
C'est quoi?
Avant de se déplacer, on dit à nos
concitoyens d'appeler le 15.
Partout sur le territoire, quel
que soit l'heure du jour de la
nuit, en appelant le 15, vous avez
un numéro de téléphone qui vous
proposera la situation la plus
adaptée à votre problème de santé.
En complément de cette promotion
du 15, nous avons revalorisé les
horaires de nuit pour prendre en
compte la pénibilité.
Nous avons revalorisé les actes
qui sont réalisés par les médecins
généralistes.
Je veux les saluer, car ils se
sont organisés pour prendre en
charge les urgences.
Nous avons développé des outils de
télémédecine.
L'été dernier, la fréquentation
des services d'urgence a enfin
diminué, pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans.
C'est grâce à nos mesures.
En complément, nous continuons à
travailler sur l'attractivité de
ces métiers de l'urgence qui sont
des métiers particulièrement
pénibles.
La lutte contre l'intérim médical
a permis de mobiliser deux
leviers: le premier ayant permis
de faire revenir dans les équipes
médicales des professionnels pour
travailler de façon plus pérenne.
Ensuite a été mis en place une
solidarité qui permet de mieux
répondre à l'ensemble des
territoires.
Il faut préciser toutefois une
chose: la réponse à l'aide
médicale urgente, c'est-à-dire la
réponse aux véritables situations
d'urgence, vitales ou
fonctionnelles, est maintenue
voire renforcée dans les
territoires où il y a des
changements de population.
L'engagement du président de la
République a été pris pour nos
services d'urgence à échelon fin
2024.
Ce sera obtenu par la régulation
médicale qui se généralise au sein
des services d'accès aux soins sur
l'ensemble du territoire, par
l'amélioration du fonctionnement
de l'hôpital par l'amélioration
des services d'urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Sophie
Taillé-Polian.
J'ai sauté une ligne.
Je suis navrée.
Monsieur Laurent Panifous!
- Laurent Panifous: Merci.
Vous êtes toute pardonnée.
J'adresse ma question à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances.
Chacun connaît ici les grandes
difficultés rencontrées par les
EHPAD en France.
Que ce soit la crise Covid, les
problèmes de recrutement, mais
aussi les difficultés financières.
Nous concentrons notre attention
sur la réponse qui doit prévaloir
dans nos établissements sur la
qualité d'accueil.
Les conditions doivent être créées
d'un exercice réaliste de ces
métiers.
Il doit y avoir un cadre
réglementaire et budgétaire, mais
aussi fiscal suffisant et stable.
Il doit être à la hauteur du
besoin d'accompagnement de nos
aînés.
Mais les EHPAD publics ne vont
plus bénéficier du régime de la
TVA.
Il permettait de bénéficier de la
récupération de la TVA sur les
dépenses d'exploitation, mais il
permettait aussi une exonération
sur les salaires.
Les sommes en jeu sont
considérables.
L'administration fiscale avait
pourtant validé l'application de
ce régime depuis de nombreuses
années.
Je connais une structure de 200
places.
Les sommes dues approchent le
million d'euros.
Je me tourne vers vous afin qu'une
décision soit prise au plus vite
pour soulager ces établissements
publics, déjà en grande
difficulté.
Cette mesure et sa rétroactivité
seront probablement la mesure de
trop.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Christophe
Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Merci pour votre question.
Elle me permet d'abord de saluer
le travail exceptionnel de nos
EHPAD dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile.
Il y a des questions de défiance
liées à la crise sanitaire ou à
l'affaire Orpea.
Le taux d'occupation est
extrêmement bas pour plusieurs
d'entre eux.
Votre question aborde également la
question d'une difficulté plus
récente à cause d'une décision du
Conseil d'Etat.
Elle confirme l'assujettissement
des établissements publics à la
taxe sur les salaires.
Cela a conduit à des situations
extrêmement graves.
Certains établissements ont des
arriérés qui datent de plusieurs
années.
Cela a pesé sur la trésorerie de
ces établissements.
Dès la confirmation de cette
décision, nous avons saisi nos
administrations pour faire un
point précis sur la situation.
Nous avons étudié des souplesses
de recouvrement pour accompagner
ces établissements et faire en
sorte qu'ils ne se retrouvent pas
dans des difficultés qui seraient
insurmontables.
Ce soutien est déjà matérialisé
depuis plusieurs mois, notamment
en fin d'année, avec l'abondement
de crédits supplémentaires en fin
d'exercice.
Ils ont été délégués par l'Etat.
Le bouclier tarifaire a été étendu
à l'ensemble des établissements
médico-sociaux.
Ce soutien va passer aussi par une
réflexion que nous allons conduire
sur le modèle économique des
EHPAD, en lien avec les
départements, pour leur apporter
une réponse et une solution
définitive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Sophie
Taillé-Polian pour le groupe
écologiste.
- Sophie Taillé-Polian: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Je voudrais féliciter madame
Justine Triet pour la Palme d'or
qu'elle a reçue samedi.
Dans son discours, elle a précisé
à quel point son oeuvre n'aurait
pu voir le jour sans l'exception
culturelle et combien cette
dernière avait du mal à endiguer
la marchandisation de la culture.
Elle s'est inquiétée pour les
jeunes réalisateurs.
Elle a surtout osé, crime de
lèse-macronie, exprimer ce qui
pèse sur le coeur de tant de
Françaises et de Français: une
réforme des retraites injuste et
passée en force.
Selon vous, madame la ministre de
la Culture, elle a certainement
tort.
Là n'est pas la question.
Le monde nous envie l'exception
culturelle.
Cela contribue à notre rayonnement
culturel.
C'est aussi le triomphe
d'après-guerre de l'indépendance
de la culture face aux tentations
autoritaires de faire de l'art un
outil de propagande du pouvoir.
Grâce à elle, les artistes n'ont
pas à plaire à ceux qui les
gouvernent.
Grâce à elle, le cinéma français
est vivant.
Quand je vous entends parler
d'ingratitude et cela me choque
profondément.
Vous accuser des artistes qui ont
bénéficié d'aides publiques de
faire preuve d'ingratitude.
Laurent Wauquiez a supprimé les
subventions à un théâtre parce que
ses propos ne lui avaient pas plu.
Nous attendons de votre part la
condamnation ferme de la multitude
de propos issus de la majorité,
visant à faire taire les artistes
subventionnés.
Je pense notamment au ministre de
l'Industrie.
Quand il s'agit de demander aux
grandes entreprises où est
l'argent, il n'y a plus personne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Rima Abdul Malak.
- Rima Abdul Malak: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je suis fondamentalement attachée
à la liberté d'expression.
Je viens de le dire à votre
collègue, Sarah Legrain.
Mais je trouve important de
rétablir la vérité quand il y a,
sur le fond, des propos ultra
excessifs par rapport à la
réalité.
Où sont les menaces qui pèsent sur
la culture?
Vous avez un parti qui veut
censurer des artistes, qui veut
boycotter des journalistes.
Il veut conditionner les aides du
CNC à des films qui feraient la
promotion de l'histoire de France.
Cela a été dit en commission des
Affaires culturelles.
Vous avez un parti qui veut
privatiser l'audiovisuel public.
Vous avez un président de région
qui distribue des bons et des
mauvais points et qui décide de
couper des subventions à ceux qui
s'expriment en désaccord avec lui.
Voilà les dérives autoritaires.
Voilà les dérives qui menacent
notre modèle culturel.
La ministre que vous avez face à
vous défend le plus haut budget
que la culture a obtenu depuis que
le ministère de la Culture existe.
Elle défend la liberté de création
à chaque fois qu'elle est menacée.
La ministre de la Culture est
aux côté des élus et des
collectivités de la région
Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes pour trouver
des solutions.
Il y a quelques semaines, une
tribune a été signée par des
artistes et des professionnels de
la culture contre la réforme des
retraites.
Ils ne sont pas d'accord avec le
gouvernement.
Est-ce que vous pouvez regarder le
détail de cette liste?
Vous verrez qu'il y a plusieurs
subventions que nous accordons.
Nous n'avons pas baissé nos
subventions.
Nous les avons même augmentées
pour faire face à l'inflation.
Cela n'a donc jamais été un
critère.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Christine Engrand
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Christine Engrand: Les TPE sont
aux abois.
Le nombre de défaillances
d'entreprises augmente au premier
trimestre 2023.
La majorité d'entre elles concerne
des entreprises de moins de 10
salariés.
Peut-être que cela aurait été
entendu, si cela provenait du
cabinet de conseil McKinsey.
Plusieurs personnes ont écrit au
président de la République en
début d'année et elles sont
présentes dans cet hémicycle.
Ils n'ont eu comme réponse qu'un
silence assourdissant.
Une des salariés ne perçoit plus
de salaires depuis le début de
l'année, et il en va de même pour
son mari.
La feuille de placo est passée de
0,90 euro à 4,20 euros.
Les tuiles s'achètent aux
enchères.
Une des salariés est à la tête
d'une société de nettoyage de 10
salariés.
Elle a voté pour vous et elle vous
a écrit.
Elle dénonce les charges qui
l'écrasent.
Cela ne serait pas arrivé avec
notre proposition.
Nous dénonçons une absence du
gouvernement.
Vous croyez que le petit ne peut
arriver à rien.
Incapable de trouver des
solutions, le gouvernement qui
promettait une retraite à 1200
euros pour tous pendant la
campagne présidentielle, préfère
tenter une inquisition contre le
Rassemblement National.
Si nos idées sont populaires,
c'est qu'elles proviennent des
Français, qui travaillent et qui
entreprennent.
Quelles sont vos propositions
concrètes à mettre en place
immédiatement avant qu'il ne soit
définitivement trop tard?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
D'abord, je voudrais vous dire, à
l'endroit des deux entrepreneurs
que vous mentionnez, que c'est
très bien, d'écrire au président
de la République, mais que je suis
aussi à leur disposition.
Je vous garantis que l'on répond à
chacun des courriers.
Pour ce qui est des difficultés,
si vos collègues me laissent
éventuellement finir, j'aimerais
apporter une réponse précise.
J'ajouterai, aux côtés des
onomatopées charmantes de monsieur
Sébastien Chenu, qu'il y a des
entreprises qui connaissent des
difficultés dans chaque
département.
Nous accompagnons des
entrepreneurs en difficulté tous
les jours.
Nous assurons des échelonnements
de créances.
Nous assurons la mise en place du
bouclier tarifaire et de
l'amortisseur.
Nous accompagnons les TPE en
difficulté.
Vous citez une étude.
Je ne vais pas vous citer
l'intégralité des études que le
ministère de l'Economie a en main.
Il y en a beaucoup.
Par honnêteté intellectuelle, ça
dépend du secteur et de la taille
des entreprises.
Il y a un chiffre qui a été
partagé aujourd'hui par
l'observatoire du financement.
Vous avez une réalité, au mois de
février dernier: l'accès aux
crédits de nos TPE et PME a
augmenté de 5%.
Vous avez aussi des entrepreneurs
qui sont en difficulté, pour
certains, mais qui sont confiants
pour leur trésorerie.
Qu'il y ait, et je pense que l'on
peut se mettre d'accord là-dessus,
des entreprises avec des
difficultés, il y en a.
Mais l'immense majorité de nos TPE
et PME arrive à rembourser leurs
PGE.
Je suis plus que disponible pour
accompagner les deux que vous avez
mentionnées.
Je me tiens à leur disposition à
mon adresse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Sophie
Mette pour le groupe démocrate.
- Sophie Mette: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Rima Abdul Malak.
En France, il est un domaine qui
pèse 19 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires.
Il repose sur seulement 150.000
professionnels et 60.000
entreprises.
Pour la grande majorité, elles
sont individuelles.
J'évoque les métiers d'arts qui
font la fierté de notre pays dans
le monde entier.
Vous avez annoncé le déploiement
d'une stratégie nationale en
faveur des métiers d'art.
C'est inédit pour un système
puissant et que tous les Français
connaissent.
Les savoir-faire français en
matière d'artisanat et de l'art, à
la fois traditionnels et
innovants, sont d'une richesse
infinie.
En témoignent les compétences
exceptionnelles mobilisées pour la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris.
Les défis sont grands.
A commencer par celui du
recrutement.
Il est crucial de faire connaître
nos ateliers, d'encourager la
création française, de valoriser
ces métiers auprès des jeunes et
de donner une réponse à cette
orientation.
Une partie de ces défis doit être
relevée par l'outil puissant de
démocratisation culturelle qu'est
le pass culture.
Enfin, il faut rappeler que les
métiers d'art s'inscrivent contre
la production de masques jetables.
Le recyclage plastique est
courant, ainsi que la
réutilisation de chutes de tissus
ou de matières organiques.
C'est notre rôle que d'encourager
les pratiques durables.
Cela passe par le développement de
réseaux de proximité et par une
logique d'économie circulaire et
de production locale.
Comment mettre en place des
mesures efficaces qui se
déclineront sur tous nos
territoires et notamment dans la
ruralité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Rima Abdul Malak.
- Rima Abdul Malak: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Merci de cet hommage à nos
artisans d'art.
Nous avons lancé ce matin une
stratégie nationale pour les
métiers d'art.
Nous y travaillons depuis
plusieurs mois.
Nous fédérons tous les
professionnels des différents
écosystèmes de ces métiers,
publics comme privés.
Nous avons une priorité donnée sur
la relève et la jeunesse, sur la
transmission de ces métiers aux
nouvelles générations.
Cela va passer par des stages et
des ateliers découvertes à
l'école.
Cela va passer par la mobilisation
de nos institutions culturelles.
Cela va passer aussi par le pass
culture.
Il y a plus de 700 activités
métiers d'art qui vont être
proposées aux jeunes entre 15 et
19 ans.
Pour ce qui est des territoires,
c'est le deuxième axe le plus
prioritaire de notre stratégie.
Nous avons prévu le déploiement
d'un appel à projet pour créer des
pôles territoriaux des métiers
d'art.
Il y aura un travail sur le label
entreprise du patrimoine vivant
pour le renforcer encore plus.
Il y aura aussi une redynamisation
des journées européennes des
métiers d'art.
Il y aura une facilitation des
expositions, notamment.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à Manon Meunier pour
La France Insoumise.
- Manon Meunier: Madame la
Première ministre, vous êtes à
contre-courant de l'histoire.
Vous relancez le charbon et le
gaz, en pleine transition
écologique.
Après tout, nous avons le temps.
Vous avez même proclamé la pause
environnementale.
Après tout, il n'y a pas
d'urgence.
Pourtant, ce jeudi, les
scientifiques ont découvert que le
ralentissement des courants
océaniques profonds, entraîné par
la fonte des glaces, est beaucoup
plus rapide que prévu.
En quoi cela nous concerne?
L'océan est à la fois un
formidable puits de carbone et le
premier poumon de la planète.
Il nous apporte plus de 50% de
l'oxygène que nous respirons.
C'est grâce à un faible équilibre
entre la diversité marine et ces
courants profonds.
Ils font circuler l'oxygène.
Le ralentissement de ces courants
océaniques, c'est grave.
Cela aggrave encore plus le
changement climatique.
Nous pensions qu'il y avait
urgence à agir, mais c'est encore
plus grave que ça.
Admettons que vous n'ayez pas
saisi l'urgence.
Au bout de six rapports du GIEC et
deux rappels à l'ordre pour
inaction climatique!
Maintenant, il est plus que temps
de sortir de votre déni.
En toute bienveillance, je vous le
dis, les décisions que vous prenez
ne sont pas sans conséquences.
Elles déterminent les conditions
futures
d'habitabilité de notre planète.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Bérangère
Couillard.
- Bérangère Couillard: Vous faites
référence à une étude publiée il y
a quelques jours dans une revue
scientifique de renom.
Elle montre que les courants
océaniques profonds ralentissent
plus rapidement que prévu, en
effet.
Ce phénomène est notamment lié à
la fonte des glaces de
l'Antarctique.
C'est une conséquence du
réchauffement climatique.
Il est documenté depuis plusieurs
années.
Mais les données récentes montrent
que l'accélération du phénomène
est en cours.
Les impacts sont nombreux.
Moins d'oxygène disponible pour la
diversité marine, moins de
stockage carbone, et le
dérèglement du climat des régions
littorales.
Le gouvernement est pleinement
engagé dans la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Nous allons tenir la trajectoire
pour respecter l'accord de Paris.
La Première ministre a présenté le
22 mai sa vision pour une
déclinaison sectorielle et
territoriale de nos émissions.
Nous travaillons aussi sur un
scénario pessimiste, mais
crédible, d'adaptation à +4 degrés
de plus en France.
La mobilisation de la France dans
le green deal européen est actée.
L'océan est à la croisée des
enjeux climatiques et
environnementaux et du
développement durable.
Pour agir, il nous faut connaître
nos écosystèmes marins.
C'est pourquoi une place centrale
sera donnée au panel international
pour la durabilité de l'océan.
C'est l'équivalent du GIEC de
l'océan.
Vos accusations sont infondées.
Le gouvernement est pleinement
impliqué.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Madame la députée?
- Sophie Mette: Vos actions sont
plus qu'inutiles.
Elles sont néfastes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Hubert
Wulfranc.
- Hubert Wulfranc: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre des
Transports, anticipant les
conclusions de l'enquête lancée en
janvier dernier par la Commission
européenne, vous avez annoncé, la
semaine dernière, la liquidation
de Fret SNCF.
Cela est assorti de l'abandon de
30% du trafic de l'opérateur
public, la suppression de 500
emplois de cheminots ou la cession
d'actifs aux concurrents de Fret
SNCF.
Mais nous avons besoin de
développer le fret ferroviaire.
Cette décision nous prive d'un
outil industriel majeur pour le
report modal de la route vers le
rail.
Pour donner le change, vous avez
annoncé vouloir consolider les 170
millions d'euros que vous
consacrez au fret.
Vous avez annoncé 4 milliards sur
France Relance.
La logique de fuite en avant
libérale qui est la vôtre ne va
pas permettre de relever le défi
climatique.
Les plans de relance qui se sont
succédés depuis 20 ans n'ont pas
permis à notre pays de sortir de
l'impasse.
Les députés communistes vont
déclencher une commission
d'enquête sur ce que nous appelons
une véritable capitulation
gouvernementale.
Allez-vous enfin vous battre pour
faire évoluer les règles
européennes autorisant les Etats à
reprendre la main sur leur système
de transport stratégique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Je connais votre engagement pour
le ferroviaire.
Nous avons encore discuté
récemment sur les petites lignes.
Je partage votre engagement.
Je crois à l'avenir du fret
ferroviaire et d'un fret
ferroviaire public dans notre
pays.
Quelle est la situation?
La Commission européenne a engagé
une procédure.
Nous avons cherché à l'éviter.
C'est malheureusement,
aujourd'hui, une réalité.
Je ne vais pas mentir aux salariés
de Fret SNCF.
Nous avons besoin de développer le
fret ferroviaire en France.
Nous avons besoin d'un opérateur
public.
C'est pourquoi nous avons trouvé
une solution rapide.
Il n'y aura pas d'accord au
rabais.
Il n'y aura aucun licenciement, ni
report modal.
Attendre 18 mois, ce serait la
solution de facilité, la solution
démagogique.
Qui sera motivé pour relancer le
fret ferroviaire, si l'on ne sait
pas quelle est la perspective pour
Fret SNCF?
Je ne vais pas prendre ce risque.
C'est la raison pour laquelle, et
non pas pour donner le change,
mais pour développer le fret
ferroviaire, nous allons
réinvestir dans le fret
ferroviaire.
Les montants que vous évoquez ne
sont pas minimes.
Nous n'avons jamais fait ça.
330 millions d'euros par an en
soutien à l'exploitation du fret
ferroviaire.
Ce n'est pas minimiser les dégâts
ou essayer de limiter les choses,
mais préparer et bâtir ensemble un
avenir pour le fret ferroviaire
public.
- Hubert Wulfranc: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Merci, madame la présidente.
La Deutsch Bahn, l'opérateur
ferroviaire allemand, est aussi
sous le coup d'une commission
d'enquête.
Le couple franco-allemand, moteur
de l'Europe, n'est donc pas en
capacité de défendre l'intérêt
national de chacun de ses
pays-membres.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre, excusez-moi.
- Clément Beaune: Vous avez
raison, elle est sous le coup
d'une procédure.
Nos homologues allemands cherchent
aussi à trouver une solution
rapide.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Constance Le Grip.
- Constance Le Grip: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la ministre de la Culture,
oui, la France aime le cinéma.
Elle l'a toujours prouvé.
Notre pays a toujours su garder un
cinéma fort, créatif, reconnu,
admiré, chatoyant.
Nous pouvons être heureux d'avoir
le plus grand festival de cinéma
du monde, le festival de Cannes,
dont la dernière édition vient de
se terminer.
En trois ans, ce sont deux Palmes
d'or qui sont venues récompenser
des films français.
Ce sont deux réalisatrices
françaises aussi.
C'est au talent de ces
réalisatrices, des acteurs, des
techniciens, de tous les métiers
du cinéma que l'on doit ces
récompenses.
C'est aussi l'exception culturelle
française qui rend possible
l'éclosion des talents, qui
accompagne et soutient, qui
finance ces talents.
Oui, il y a un modèle de
financement du cinéma français, né
avec André Malraux.
Tous les gouvernants et ministres
de la Culture ont suivi ce modèle.
Ce modèle nous est envié.
Il permet la diversité de la
création.
Ce sont les Français, très
nombreux à se rendre dans les
salles de cinéma, qui nous le
montrent.
Oui, nous aimons le cinéma, n'en
déplaise aux esprits grincheux et
injustes.
Madame la ministre, pouvez-vous
nous rappeler les caractéristiques
de ce modèle français du
financement du cinéma?
Il faut nous rappeler la
mobilisation pendant la crise du
Covid et dire quels
sont vos projets concrets en
matière de cinéma?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Rima Abdul Malak.
- Rima Abdul Malak: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Effectivement, il faut se réjouir
de la bonne santé de notre filière
du cinéma et de l'audiovisuel.
J'étais, la semaine dernière, à
Cannes, pour annoncer 350 millions
d'euros, un nouveau plan pour
financer le développement de nos
infrastructures de tournage et
doubler nos capacités de studios
de tournage à horizon 2030 et
doubler nos capacités de
formation.
Il y a l'enjeu de la relève.
Il faut pouvoir soutenir plus la
formation de nouveaux talents
créatifs et techniques.
C'est un engagement fort de 350
millions d'euros d'argent public.
Je rappelle aussi l'importance de
la régulation et d'avoir amené les
plates-formes américaines, qui
sont aujourd'hui nos partenaires,
à investir dans le financement de
la création.
Ce sont des obligations à hauteur
de 20% que la France a mises.
En Espagne, c'est 3,5%.
On fait le maximum pour développer
cette exception culturelle et ce
modèle.
Ce modèle permet la diversité des
films.
Il n'est jamais décidé en amont de
soutenir un film pour des raisons
de rentabilité.
Ce sont les conditions de la
diversité qui sont mises en place.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Patrick Hetzel: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre chargé des
Comptes publics.
La Cour des Comptes estime la
fraude sociale entre 6 et 8
milliards d'euros par an et
considère que la France ne lutte
pas assez contre ce fléau.
Vous venez de faire des annonces
concernant un plan de lutte contre
les fraudes sociales ce matin.
Je m'étonne de ces annonces, plus
de 30 mois après le rendu de la
commission d'enquête sur ce sujet.
Si vous reprenez quelques
propositions formulées dans le
rapport, je constate toutefois
quelques angles morts importants.
Ainsi, vous ne parlez pas de
l'ordonnance dématérialisée,
mesure qui a permis en Espagne
d'économiser plus d'un milliard
d'euros.
Concernant les cartes Vitales,
vous annoncez plus de 2,3
millions de cartes désactivées.
Il y avait un problème avec les
cartes Vitales.
Ce problème avait été nié.
Il y a encore du travail, monsieur
le ministre.
Par ailleurs, vous voulez
fusionner la carte Vitale et la
carte d'identité.
Dommage qu'au passage cela
revienne à abandonner la carte
Vitale biométrique.
Ce qui est embêtant, c'est que
vous êtes sur un effet d'annonce.
Le ministère de l'Intérieur qui
s'occupe des cartes nationales
d'identité indique qu'il n'a
jamais été consulté par vos
services.
Ma question est simple.
Comment allez-vous faire pour que
ce sentier soit réalisé avant fin
la fin de ce quinquennat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Patrick Hetzel,
je vous remercie pour votre
intervention et votre question.
Vous connaissez très bien ces
sujets de fraudes sociales.
Vous avez travaillé depuis
plusieurs années sur ces sujets.
J'ai présenté ce matin un plan
complet sur le sujet qui s'attaque
à la fraude aux cotisations
sociales, à la fraude aux
prestations maladie, aux
allocations sociales.
Sur les prestations maladie, il y
a des mesures importantes qui
comme celle de travailler à la
fusion entre la carte d'identité
la carte Vitale.
Sur ce sujet, beaucoup de choses
ont été dites et écrites.
Pour faire la lumière sur tout ça,
nous avons missionner l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales qui
nous a remis un rapport.
Depuis l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron 2017, nous avons procédé à
la désactivation de 2,3 millions
de cartes Vitales en surnombre.
Ce sont des cartes qui étaient
hors d'usage.
Il n'y a plus de carte Vitale
surnuméraire dans notre pays.
Les chiffres sont transparents.
Il en reste 942.
Nous allons tout faire pour les
désactiver.
Ensuite, le rapport écarte la mise
en place de la carte biométrique.
Ca coûte très cher.
250 millions d'euros par an.
Il y a un enjeu de
constitutionnalité à cause des
fuites de données.
Enfin, les professionnels de santé
disent faut prendre les empreintes
digitales des patients.
Quand vous êtes cloué au lit,
c'est difficile de fournir votre
main pour aller donner vos
empreintes digitales à votre
place.
Il n'y a pas de désaccord au sein
du gouvernement.
Nous avons communiqué ce matin
avec Gérald Darmanin et François
Braun pour annoncer que l'on
allait lancer une mission de
préfiguration.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse,
monsieur Patrick Hetzel?
- Patrick Hetzel: Encore une fois,
ce que vous proposez, ça pose un
certain nombre de problèmes.
On aura l'occasion d'y revenir.
Il y a un angle mort qui est
inquiétant.
A aucun moment vous ne mentionnez
les fraudes en bande organisée.
C'est un vrai problème.
Il faut s'y attaquer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à François Jolivet.
- François Jolivet: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre des Comptes
publics, vous avez présenté hier
votre plan de lutte contre la
fraude sociale.
Ces annonces faites s'inscrivent
dans un plan gouvernemental bien
plus large qui fait suite à un
travail transpartisan.
Le combat que vous menez devient,
à mon sens, une grande cause
nationale, ou en tous les cas un
fait marquant de ce quinquennat.
Je veux me féliciter de la mise à
l'agenda de ce plan gouvernemental
de lutte contre les fraudes.
Il n'y a pas de petites fraudes
qui seraient plus acceptables que
d'autres.
Il n'y a que de la fraude.
Tout fraudeur doit être démasqué,
sanctionné et condamné.
Plusieurs annonces fortes ont été
dévoilées hier, comme l'obligation
de résider en France pour
bénéficier des prestations
sociales, ou la fusion de la carte
Vitale et de la carte d'identité.
D'autres annonces doivent être
faites prochainement, car la lutte
contre la fraude devient
malheureusement un sport national
pour certains.
Nous souhaitons que cela devienne
une cause nationale.
Ces mesures s'ajoutent à celles
annoncées il y a quelques semaines
pour les luttes contre la fraude
fiscale, avec la création d'un
service de renseignements
spécifiques, avec un personnel
dédié.
Notre Assemblée examinera dans
quelques jours le projet de loi
visant à donner de nouveaux
moyens.
Je crois que le Sénat vient
d'adopter cela.
Toutes les annonces vont dans le
bon sens.
La tolérance zéro et l'assurance
de l'Etat envoie le message que
les fraudeurs ne sont pas
tranquilles.
Vous voulez passer aux actes.
Le soutien de la Première
ministre, vous l'avez.
Quelle est votre idée sur le
calendrier?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
La question de la lutte contre la
fraude est fondamentale.
Vous avez participé au groupe de
travail, je vous en remercie.
La lutte est fondamentale pour des
raisons de données publiques et de
finances publiques.
Elle est fondamentale pour des
raisons de cohésion nationale.
Quand on part de la fraude
sociale, c'est aussi important.
Les Français doivent continuer à
avoir confiance en notre modèle
social.
Garder le contrôle sur notre
modèle social, c'est reprendre le
contrôle sur ce qui est donné.
C'est le sens du plan que j'ai
donné.
J'étais avec plusieurs d'entre
vous à la caisse d'allocations
familiales.
Nous avons échangé avec les agents
qui nous ont présenté les enjeux.
8 millions d'euros ont été
indûment perçus via un réseau de
fraude mafieux.
C'était via la Roumanie.
Voilà ce que nous avons en face de
nous.
Nous devons lutter contre ça.
Cela nécessite des moyens.
Dans le plan que j'ai annoncé, il
y a des moyens absolument inédits.
Les 5 années à venir, et ça
commencera dès l'année prochaine,
nous allons augmenter l'effectif
de la lutte contre la fraude
sociale dans les caisses de
Sécurité sociale.
Nous allons investir 1 milliard
d'euros dans de nouveaux systèmes
d'information pour être plus
efficaces dans le croisement de
données.
Sur le calendrier, un certain nombre
de mesures vont s'appliquer très
vite.
En juillet,
fin du versement d'allocations
sociales sur les comptes bancaires
étrangers hors Union Européenne.
Beaucoup d'autres mesures sont à
venir.
C'est un travail global du
gouvernement.
Je suis en charge de la lutte
contre cela, notamment avec
Jean-Christophe Combe.
Je sais compter sur les
parlementaires pour avancer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Emmanuel Taché de
la Pagerie.
- Emmanuel Taché de la Pagerie:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
243 jours de sécheresse par an à
l'horizon 2050, cette prévision
vraisemblable et terrifiante
condamnerait à court terme
l'ensemble du sud de la France,
d'après diverses enquêtes
concordantes.
A titre d'exemple, si cette
échéance s'avère vraie, la ville
d'Arles serait la ville la plus
invivable de France.
Vous comprendrez l'urgence qui
convoque l'Etat à prendre
conscience de cet enjeu vital,
soulevant la question de
l'agriculture, de
l'agroalimentaire, de la santé, de
l'urbanisme, des transports, des
écoles et du nucléaire.
Si le président de la République a
présenté le 30 mars dernier le
Plan eau, qu'en est-il de ses
ambitions?
Le génie français a toujours été
mobilisé pour irriguer notre pays,
des Gallo-romains, aux
infrastructures de Paul Riquet,
jusqu'aux travaux d'envergure de
l'après-guerre.
Le dérèglement climatique ne peut
avoir raison de siècles
d'ingénierie et condamner les
territoires entiers à la
sécheresse, dont celui que je
représente.
Pourquoi ne pas faire d'Arles et
de son territoire une incarnation
de ce plan?
Monsieur le ministre, êtes-vous
prêt à prendre les mesures
historiques et nécessaires afin de
préserver le pays d'Arles, et plus
amplement tout le Sud de l'aridité
imminente qui le menace?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, d'abord, merci
pour votre question.
Dans votre question, vous insistez
sur la réalité du dérèglement
climatique, sur la justesse de la
stratégie du gouvernement qui
consiste à dire qu'il nous faut
travailler à 4 degrés.
Cela tranche avec certains
commentaires qui nous étaient
arrivés d'entendre de ce côté de
l'hémicycle pour remettre en cause
l'atténuation des politiques que
nous portons.
D'abord, vous l'avez dit, l'enjeu
du Plan eau, ce ne sont pas les
effets d'annonce.
C'est des affaires concrètes.
500 chantiers ont été lancés
depuis l'été dernier.
A Arles, de manière générale, il y
a le soutien de l'Etat.
D'abord, un plan de 9 millions
d'euros pour restaurer le canal de
cette ville.
5 millions d'euros par an dans un
dispositif de lutte contre les
fuites.
Le recrutement d'agents pour
vérifier en amont là où les choses
se passent.
Je pourrais poursuivre.
Arles est une région pilote de
manière plus globale.
Il y a un enjeu plus vaste qui est
une étude plus large conduite dans
le cadre de l'étang de Berre.
C'est un problème de pollution à
l'eau douce avec les circuits
hydroélectriques.
Une partie de cet excédent des
eaux douces, au lieu de se
demander comment on la rapproche
de la mer, on pourrait se demander
si on ne peut pas la ramener vers
le fleuve.
C'est quelque chose de plus
ambitieux.
Ca nous permettrait de régler 2
problèmes en 1.
La pollution menace aujourd'hui
l'écosystème de l'étang de Berre.
Je suis à votre disposition pour
avancer sur cette question.
Nous voulons protéger de manière
concrète nos concitoyens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse?
- Emmanuel Taché de la Pagerie: Je
vous remercie, monsieur le
ministre.
Vous l'avez soulevé, cette
question dépasse les clivages
politiques et ne souffre pas qu'on
les relève, qu'on les soulève.
Effectivement, il y a un vrai
travail à faire concernant l'eau.
Il est nécessaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Robin Reda.
- Robin Reda: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre, l'état
d'urgence de la santé mentale à
l'école est déclaré.
Dans nos écoles, trop de nos
enfants vont mal.
C'est le constat des enseignants,
des parents, des professionnels de
la santé scolaire.
La santé scolaire est donnée après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Elle avait permis de réparer une
jeunesse meurtrie dans son âme.
La pandémie a lourdement affecté
notre jeunesse.
Les angoisses climatiques,
géopolitiques, économiques
hypothèquent son avenir.
Il y a une certaine forme de
déshumanisation qui s'incarne dans
la famille, de nos jours.
Il y a du harcèlement scolaire.
Dans ce monde violent et dans ce
monde de toutes les angoisses,
nous devons faire du défi de la
santé mentale de nos jeunes une
priorité.
Les dépressions, les tentatives de
suicide n'ont jamais été aussi
nombreuses, et ce, dès le plus
jeune âge.
Pour orienter les jeunes, il faut
construire une mission collective
dans nos établissements avec les
médecins scolaires, les
psychologues, les infirmiers et
infirmières.
Il faut décloisonner les missions
et mieux intervenir dans les
établissements.
Il faut que les enseignants, les
CPE, les assistants d'éducation
soient formés.
Ils ont tous un rôle à jouer dans
la vigilance du quotidien.
L'école, ce n'est pas un cabinet
médical ou un hôpital.
C'est un lieu idéal pour la
prévention, pour s'y sentir bien,
pour apprendre les savoirs
fondamentaux.
Il faut y aller avec un esprit
sain dans un corps sain.
Comment pouvez-vous conjuguer nos
efforts pour faire en sorte que la
médecine scolaire puisse servir le
bien-être et la réussite de nos
élèves?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, le rapport que
vous avez remis à la commission
des finances le 11 mai dernier
précise et montre bien à quel
point la santé scolaire est
essentielle dans la détection et
la prise en charge des souffrances
psychiques et mentales de nos
élèves.
Les drames récents qui ont pu
toucher nos élèves le montrent
bien.
Permettez-moi d'adresser mes
pensées les plus sincères et les
plus émues à la famille de
Lindsay.
C'est pour prévenir ces situations
dramatiques nous prenons le
premier train des mesures
concernant la santé mentale des
élèves.
D'abord, dès la rentrée prochaine,
les CPE seront formés au
secourisme en santé mentale, et
ils disposeront des outils
nécessaires pour affronter les
difficultés des élèves.
Ensuite, une équipe sera chargée
de mettre en place un protocole
permettant de prendre en charge
les élèves en souffrance.
Nous voulons aussi généraliser un
dispositif que le ministre de la
Santé a mis en place.
Un parcours de suivi de séances de
psy sera gratuit.
Nous allons aussi systématiser le
numéro de prévention nationale du
suicide dans les carnets de
correspondance d'élèves.
Ce sera fait à la rentrée.
C'est une plate-forme avec des
professionnels très bien formés.
Ce sujet de la santé mentale,
c'est un sujet qui nous préoccupe
tous.
Vous pouvez compter sur votre
mobilisation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Frédéric Mathieu.
- Frédéric Mathieu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs, à Bruges,
j'ai appris la mise en place d'un
sas dans lequel vous comptez
placer des sans-abri en vue des JO
de 2024.
Ce sera près d'un site de
traitement de déchets et de métaux
lourds.
Cela inquiète à juste raison.
On nous dit que les premières
interventions seront en juin, ou
en septembre.
Je suis absolument consterné par
l'amateurisme de l'opération qui
cache mal une totale indifférence
à l'égard de la dignité humaine.
En guise de prélude en la matière,
le préfet s'est illustré récemment
en l'expulsion d'une famille dans
un hébergement d'urgence dans une
autre commune que celle où elle
était hébergée.
Avec à la clé, une famille en
détresse.
Faute d'avoir des explications
claires de la part du préfet,
pourriez-vous nous expliquer votre
méthode, si toutefois, il y en a
une?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Frédéric
Mathieu, merci de votre question
qui va me permettre de rétablir
des vérités.
Le maire de la ville dont vous
parlez a été prévenu il y a trois
semaines de cette organisation par
le préfet.
Vous pouvez dire non, mais c'est
la réalité.
Il est indigne de penser que l'on
peut mettre en place des sites
d'accompagnement des personnes
sans-abri pour les Jeux
Olympiques.
Bien évidemment, ces
accompagnements vers les sites
d'hébergement sont mis en place en
accord avec les associations de
solidarités depuis plusieurs mois.
Si vous connaissiez mieux la
situation des sans-abri, si vous
travailliez comme moi
quotidiennement avec ces
associations, vous sauriez que ces
opérations sont un souhait des
associations de solidarités.
Comment peut-on penser bien
accueillir les personnes en
situation de grande précarité dans
un nombre aussi grand que celui
d'aujourd'hui?
Plus de 100.000 hébergés sont en
Ile-de-France, sur les 200.000
nous hébergeons chaque soir.
Chiffre jamais atteint depuis
2017!
Il est important de mieux
accompagner et c'est le sens de
cette opération en province.
Nous mettons en place un
accompagnement social
administratif de ces familles.
Aucun déplacement n'est fait sans
accord des sans-abri.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse?
- Frédéric Mathieu: Merci pour ces
non-précisions.
On reste dans le flou.
J'ai eu le maire au téléphone ce
midi.
Il n'a pas été prévenu il y a
trois semaines.
Le secrétaire adjoint de la
préfecture a annoncé qu'il y avait
des nombreux articles de journaux.
Les préfets préviennent les maires
par la presse.
C'est intéressant.
Il n'y a qu'un article de presse
qui n'ait jamais cité la ville.
Quoi qu'il en soit, le souci du
maire et mon souci en tant que
député, c'est que ces personnes
soient accueillies de manière
digne.
Vous, vous ne connaissez pas la
situation.
En Ile-de-France, c'est saturé,
mais en Bretagne aussi.
Il faut mettre les moyens pour que
les gens soient accueillies
dignement.
Il n'y a pas que l'Ile-de-France
qui est saturée en termes de
centres d'hébergement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Olivier Klein: Monsieur le
député, l'intérêt de toutes les
personnes fragiles, c'est d'être
accueillies dignement.
La Bretagne est dans une situation
plutôt digne de l'accueil des
sans-abri.
C'est un des départements de
France où il y a le moins de
sans-abri.
L'accompagnement doit se faire
dans de bonnes conditions.
Les élus doivent être associés et
ils le seront.
S'ils ne l'ont pas assez été, ils
le seront.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Valérie Rabault.
- Valérie Rabault: Madame la
Première ministre, le 19 mai,
l'Iran a perdu trois jeunes.
Ils étaient coupables d'avoir pris
part au mouvement Femme, vie,
liberté.
Le 25 mai, l'Iran exécutait en
place publique un homme.
Ces exécutions s'ajoutent aux 200
que l'on dénombre depuis le début
de l'année.
L'Union Européenne a réagi le 19
mai.
L'ONU également.
Le 23 mai, l'Allemagne a réagi.
Le 23 mai également, 108 chefs de
gouvernement, anciens chefs de
gouvernement et présidents ont
réagi en rappelant les autorités
iraniennes à rendre compte de
leurs crimes.
Depuis le 19 mai, la France n'a
rien dit.
Madame la Première ministre,
pourquoi votre gouvernement
s'est-il tu?
Le 10 mai dernier, le président du
Conseil des Droits de l'Homme de
l'ONU a désigné l'Iran pour
présider le prochain forme sociale
2023 du conseil des Droits de
l'Homme des Nations Unies.
Madame la Première ministre, c'est
un outrage aux victimes, aux morts
et aux prisonniers de la liberté.
Je vous demande une chose: faire
entendre la voix de la France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée Rabault, oui,
face à la répression brutale du
régime, l'action de la France a
visé deux exigences: d'abord,
soutenir les aspirations légitimes
des Iraniennes et des Iraniens, et
deuxièmement, s'assurer qu'il n'y
ait pas d'impunité pour les
auteurs de la répression.
Un moment fort a été la remise du
prix Franco-allemand à titre
posthume pour Mahsa Amini.
Depuis le mois d'octobre 2022,
nous avons adopté 8 trains de
sanctions européennes, dont le
dernier ce lundi 22 mai.
Ceux-ci ont visé les responsables
de la répression judiciaire.
Ils ont également visé ceux qui
appelaient à la violence contre
les manifestants, à la répression
des femmes iraniennes et à la
dénonciation d'un soi-disant
"complot occidental" qui serait
responsable du mouvement de
manifestation en Iran.
Nous avons exclu l'Iran de la
commission des Nations Unies sur
la condition de la Femme.
Nous avons établi une mission
d'établissement des faits qui
documentera la répression.
C'est un pas fondamental contre
ces violences.
Enfin, L'Union Européenne a adopté
un nouveau cadre d'actions via des
conclusions du conseil, larges et
précises.
Nous utiliserons ce cadre
d'actions.
La France et le gouvernement sont
à l'action pour sanctionner les
comportements en Iran.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse?
- Valérie Rabault: Vous n'avez
répondu à aucunes de mes deux
questions.
Quand on est France, on a une voix
particulière.
Nous sommes les pays des Droits de
l'Homme.
Nous avons été les premiers à
initier les Droits de l'Homme.
La voix de la France, elle
résonne.
Vous la faites taire.
On n'avait pas pris la parole
depuis le 19 mai.
Nous ne pouvons être des héritiers
passifs des Lumières, les
héritiers passifs des
révolutionnaires.
La voix de la France doit
s'exprimer pour les Droits de
l'Homme, les Droits des Femmes et
la liberté!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre, une réponse?
- Olivier Becht: Madame la
députée, la France, pays des
Droits de l'Homme, est à l'action,
aux côtés de l'Union Européenne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Caroline Abadie.
- Caroline Abadie: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, 3541
personnes sont décédées sur les
routes de France en 2022.
Au bilan 2023, nous compterons les
trois policiers dans le véhicule
qui a été percuté la semaine
dernière.
Il y a quelques jours, vous avez
annoncé une série de nouvelles
mesures pour protéger les
concitoyens sur les routes.
Cette majorité sera derrière vous
pour soutenir ce plan.
Nous avons toujours été derrière
vous pour soutenir les mesures qui
sont parfois impopulaires.
Avec la vitesse, l'autre grand
facteur d'accidentologie, c'est la
drogue.
Les études sur simulateur montrent
les effets du cannabis sur la
conduite.
Prise de risque augmentée, temps
de réaction augmenté, mauvaise
évaluation des distances.
23% des accidents mortels
impliquent un conducteur positif
aux stupéfiants.
Ce n'est malheureusement pas
nouveau.
Certaines affaires médiatisées
jettent un projecteur sur ces
accidents que nous devons éviter.
Je profite de cela pour souhaiter
un prompt rétablissement au
commandant de police nationale,
fauché il y a peu lors d'un
contrôle routier dans ma
circonscription.
Vous avez annoncé l'ambition de
passer de 800.000 contrôles par an
à 1 million.
C'est considérable.
Nous pourrions aussi renforcer les
peines en cas d'homicide.
Il faut être intraitable avec ceux
qui ont tué au volant de leur
voiture, alors qu'ils étaient sous
l'emprise de drogue.
En même temps, il faut penser
prévention.
Il faut restreindre les droits
d'accès pour au cannabis.
Comment, sur cette question très
interministérielle, allez-vous
limiter les accidents?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, beaucoup
d'entre nous avons déjà entendu
cette phrase plus ou moins tard
dans la soirée: "C'est bon, je
gère, je vais y arriver.
La route n'est pas longue, je
connais la route.
Ne t'inquiète pas.
Je n'ai pas bu depuis deux
heures."
Pardon, madame?
Vous faites semblant de ne pas
avoir dit ce que vous avez dit.
Vous regrettez, c'est déjà ça.
A l'issue de ces frasques, il y a
des gens qui prennent le volant.
Beaucoup considèrent qu'ils
prennent le véhicule en toute
légitimité, en considérant que
leur état est compatible avec une
conduite sûre.
A quel moment est-ce qu'on doit
commencer à considérer que dès
lors que l'on a reçu l'information
et que l'on se met en situation de
risque, faut-il revoir les peines
encourues au cas où le risque se
concrétise en drame?
C'est une réflexion ouverte.
La Première ministre a annoncé un
comité interministériel qui
permettra peut-être de créer un
nouveau délit d'homicide routier.
Je n'ai pas statué sur cette
question qui n'a pas été arbitrée.
Faut-il sans doute alourdir ou
prolonger les contrôles.
On va passer de 800.000 à plus
d'un million.
C'était seulement 470.000 il y a
quelques années.
Il y a de la prévention, de
l'information.
Votre question y participe.
Il ne faut pas qu'il y ait un seul
de nos concitoyens qui considère
que conduire en état d'ébriété ou
sous l'emprise de stupéfiant doit
être anodin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La séance des questions au
gouvernement est suspendue.